this is a story of Robert smalls a man
who was born a slave and went on to hold
one of the highest positions in
government and become a hero of the
Civil War Robert smalls was born into
slavery in South Carolina back then if a
slave had enough money they could
literally buy their freedom but smalls
wanted to buy the freedom of his whole
family a price that was more than he
could afford in 1852 while working close
to more than lines on a Confederate boat
called the CSS planter smalls hatched a
plan one night when the white officers
left the ship
smalls was left in charge with no time
to spare smalls took over the ship
rounded up the other slaves and their
families and set sails for Union waters
but smalls and his crew would have to
pass through for Confederate checkpoints
before they would be free
smalls disguised himself by wearing the
captain's jacket and straw hat and
mimicking his gait having worked on the
CSS planter for years he knew all of the
hand signals used by Confederate sailors
to pasture checkpoints the boat passed
one two and three checkpoints at the
final point which was also the most
heavily armed the smalls flashed a
signal and got to go ahead
and just like that Robert smalls and his
family literally sailed to freedom
towards the end of his life
smalls returned to the house in which he
was born a slave buying it outright from
his former slave master to live out his
days a man who went from slave to one of
the most prominent figures in America
[Music]
God sent me here to be a cowboy
and the first thing in lady told me said
when you wrote it in the arena
you said everybody's eyes were on you
she said half of them wanted you to win
the other half don't give a damn whether
you win or not because of color your
skin but I'll always want to win I've
been a professional Cowboys since 1959
dealing with racism back in the fifties
and sixth and now it's still kind of
hard people could see me at a rodeo and
because I was of a different color they
thought I was working for somebody
people want to know a lot of times why
did you want to be a capital well I had
seen a lot of black Cowboys judged
improperly but in the calf Ropin I knew
that I wasn't gonna be judged by a human
I was gonna be just by the clock the
clock was gonna determine whether I get
any money or not
[Music]
right now all I do is put on Cowboys of
color rodeos Cowboys of color features
Indians blacks Hispanics and white
cowboy was also black Cowboys in the
history book is damn near forgotten fair
many people don't even realize that New
Mexico was discovered by black men
[Music]
Chicago was founded by black men I don't
care what color you are these are the
kind of things that we want young people
to know I have four boys they are all
professional Cowboys my grand daughter
Rachel Hearn this was her first big
rodeo so it's a way of life for us I'm
76 years old that's pretty darn old for
a cowboy it's in my blood I think the
day that I lay down and can't breathe
anymore I'll still be looking for a
rodeo
[Music]
that will see children feeling insecure
about who they were because of their
skin color and their complexion but I
also witnessed that children were making
fun of each other based off their skin
color black children like calm each
other Blacky seeing their hair is like
nappy I witness this for a long time so
I created a song for the children that I
teach because I wanted to change their
perception of beauty and how they felt
about themselves and I want to encourage
them to love themselves
[Music]
I remember growing up and feeling very
insecure about the way I looked I felt
my nose was like not straight enough it
was too flat and I felt my skin was dark
also when you looked on the television
the images that were portrayed did not
reflect who I was as a black child after
attending college I took a trip to
Africa that really made me embrace and
love who I was I teach at a charter
school called Helen wah Davis Leadership
Academy we have what's called a girls
school one of the things we talk about
is self-esteem because I saw that many
of the young girls I taught didn't feel
good about themselves and they felt
uncomfortable their black skin so the do
now question is do you think skin color
determines a person's value or worth in
this society I said no because I don't
think your skin should define you in any
type of way you have to work hard and
have to tell people say and keep our
mind focused on school so that we can
make it to where we want to be I think
it's important to use music as a way to
inspire and to transform people's lives
I vowed to make this song for all black
girls to really define beauty for
themselves in life there's one thing you
should remember is more precious than
anything else
I already see a lot of the young ladies
feeling much more confident and much
more outspoken and they're much more
willing to tell their stories my black
is beautiful my black is beautiful my
black is beautiful it's what happens
when children feel good about themselves
that transfers to all two other aspects
of their lives there are many problems
we can solve in this world and mines is
to make sure that black women feel good
about themselves and black children feel
good about themselves because I think
that is the foundation of all our
education
[Music]
[Music]
back then get a lot of guys playing that
white boy music and we really don't
listen to that you know and it's going
too fast to finally get to a place where
there is now a sea of all the rainbows
of people but a lot of black kids there
we're at the point of progress I hear
from a lot of people that call the safe
and you guys made it okay for me to feel
like it was alright to be black in the
rock I hear that a lot
Brooklyn's afro punk music festival was
born in 2005 for alternative black
culture but before there was a space for
celebration a strong handful of bands
were paving the way like the band
fishbone my name is and a little more
frontman of fishbone I'm John Knoll
official basis for fishball fishbone was
formed in the late 70s and it was a Los
Angeles 1978 when too many bands who
look like this because all black band
playing punk rock and Scott we probably
counted on one hand
the crazy part about it was while we
were starting to play a lot of rock and
roll we really weren't embraced too much
by the black public we were embraced a
lot by the white public so we get a lot
of white kids coming to the show black
people ain't supposed to play rock
that's not the stereotype like people
are supposed to play RB and funk and
soul if you got dreadlocks use both be
playing reggae put on a suit and tie you
play you can play jazz right afropunk is
a celebration of rock and roll black
music for everyone it's incredible and
it draws in youth of color to say this
is for you and in a larger way than we
do you can be the beautiful black you
and rock
[Music]
you
people say that like oh like we're doing
this because black girls can do ballet
so this is an alternative it has nothing
to do with that I will tell you every
girl in this studio is classically
trained everyone doesn't ballet and
everything else
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is the Pearl Wilson and I'm a
hitch leg dancer hip Lee is a mixture of
hip-hop and ballet but really anything
that we can try to put on point that had
like a groovy feeling to it
my name is Homer Hansbrough and I'm the
founder of hit play and the founder and
director of the Chicago multicultural
Dance Center I think some people get mad
where we stay see us through hit play
it's not traditional classical ballet
we're ruining ballet well no it's not
ballet is hit play it's how we empower
our kids is how we empower the world hip
leg is so freeing and so open there's a
different culture here little hit land
movements are the hip lift stroke the
twist in and out the moon one the Vivian
and the zippy you have to have a certain
posture when you're doing that
usually here at all like straight figure
posture everything pointe shoes were
designed for ballet hit play is
different and hit play you can break
that you can just really move your torso
more you can bounce with it you know you
can have fun with it I grew up thinking
that I couldn't do ballet because of the
color of my skin that's my old studio
because I was african-american I was
often overlooked until I came to seeing
disease when I will be learned that
there was something off I'm grateful to
Mission a homer because he showed me
that I can do anything I love dancing
and hip flick it just gives you a sort
of a confidence and just a freedom like
just to be yourself this is the dance
genre that does not discriminate you
have rhythm and you can groove on point
you got it
[Music]
you